And the third and final talk, which was the best talk of the three by far, was Dave Abraham's keynote that just came out a couple days ago from C++ on C. Welcome to ADSP the Podcast, episode 198, recorded on August 26th and September 5th of 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat and don't talk about anything interesting. So I appended technical tidbits at the end, upcoming conferences, and some talks that I have watched recently. Okay. and some talks that I have watched recently. Okay, so, I mean, yeah, I was late,
第三场也是最后一场演讲，也是这三场中最好的一场，是 Dave Abraham 在几天前 C++ on C 大会上发表的主题演讲。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 198 期，录制于 2024 年 8 月 26 日和 9 月 5 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起聊天，但我们没聊什么有趣的话题。所以我会在最后补充一些技术小知识、即将举行的会议以及我最近观看的一些演讲。好吧，我是说，是的，我迟到了，
but I have very excellent reasons for being late today, which is that my house has just been utterly chaotic the past eight hours. So first of all... when you say house do you mean apartment or do you mean an actual house like in a different city i i mean i mean um both the place that i reside in which is an apartment but also house in the sense of like my household um like the people and things that are in that apartment. I see. And that has been utterly chaotic.
但我今天迟到有非常充分的理由，那就是过去八个小时里我的家里简直乱成了一锅粥。首先……当你提到“家”时，是指公寓，还是指在另一个城市的真正的房子？我是说，嗯，既指我居住的地方，也就是公寓，也指“家庭”意义上的家，比如公寓里的人和事。我明白了。那确实乱得一塌糊涂。
So first of all, we woke up this morning, and I had to cancel my first three meetings to go rescue a pigeon. where we go to NDC Tech Town I might have 10x'd all that stuff but don't worry I might 10x all this stuff too so the listener is not confused uh so that's why i'm a little bit late connor because uh there's a lot of a lot of chaos going on here well i'm sorry to hear that ramona is feeling under the weather hopefully she will bounce back before your travels yeah if you
首先，我们今天早上醒来，我不得不取消了前三个会议去救一只鸽子。当我们去 NDC Tech Town 时，我可能把所有这些事情都放大了 10 倍，但别担心，我也会把这些事情放大 10 倍，这样听众就不会感到困惑了。所以这就是我迟到的原因，Connor，因为这里发生了很多混乱。好吧，听到 Ramona 身体不舒服我很难过，希望她在你旅行前能恢复健康。是的，如果你
listen real carefully in the audio there may have been a cough or two there all right the listener will let us know if they heard that cough other than the absolute chaos how have things been things have been good things have been good i've been uh i've been keeping busy i've been keeping busy. I've been keeping busy. Got a lot of little projects. Some of them are exciting little projects. And yeah, getting all moved in. You've also had a lot of topic suggestions, which we will get into. I have had a lot of topic suggestions.
在音频中仔细听，可能会有一两声咳嗽。好吧，如果听众听到了那声咳嗽，会告诉我们的。除了绝对的混乱之外，情况怎么样？情况一直很好，我一直很忙。我一直很忙。我一直在忙。有很多小项目。其中一些是令人兴奋的小项目。是的，正在搬家。你也有很多话题建议，我们稍后会讨论。我确实有很多话题建议。
I think I tried to write them down somewhere. I just don't remember where I wrote them down. But before we do that, a correction. Last episode, I mentioned that there were multiple container adapters, and I listed three, one of which, this isn't C++, one of which turns out not actually to be a container adapter. I listed the three. What were the three you listed? They were stack, queue, and deck.
我想我试着把它们写在什么地方了。只是我不记得写在哪里了。但在那之前，先做一个更正。上一集我提到有多个容器适配器，我列举了三个，其中一个——这不是 C++——其中一个结果并不是容器适配器。我列举了那三个。你列举的那三个是什么？它们是 stack、queue 和 deque。
And it had been a while since I actually looked at the container adapter list. Deck's not a container adapter, is it? And yeah, deck is not a container adapter. So I misspoke. See, I knew that one. 2024 has been such a good year for Bryce not looking like a complete idiot during quizzes on this podcast i'm not saying like like come off as sounding smart just not like a complete idiot i can't honestly even remember how many quizzes we've had in 2024 i think that if we scored all the quizzes from
距离我上次查看容器适配器列表已经有一段时间了。Deque 不是容器适配器，对吧？是的，deque 不是容器适配器。所以我说错了。看，我知道那个。2024 年对 Bryce 来说真是美好的一年，在播客的测验中没有表现得像个彻头彻尾的白痴。我不是说要显得很聪明，只是不想表现得像个彻头彻尾的白痴。我真的记不清 2024 年我们进行过多少次测验了。我想如果我们把所有测验的分数加起来，
like start of this podcast 2023 my score would be failing and if you if you include 2024 i think my score would be a c we haven't had we haven't had a quiz though like if we did any quizzes in 2024 they all must have been in like the first two months of the year because we haven't done one recently at all i have been doing some research for this podcast you say i'm such a bad podcast host but i've been doing some research for this podcast you say i'm such a bad podcast host but i've been doing some research i've been listening to some podcasts and some of my favorite podcasts wait you've been some of my favorite podcasts you've been listening to podcasts now after four years almost you started listening and now now you're done i i i always listen to
从这个播客 2023 年开始算起，我的分数是不及格的；如果算上 2024 年，我想我的分数会是 C。不过我们并没有进行过测验，如果 2024 年有任何测验，那一定是在年初的头两个月，因为我们最近根本没做过。我一直在为这个播客做一些研究。你说我是个糟糕的播客主持人，但我一直在为这个播客做一些研究。你说我是个糟糕的播客主持人，但我一直在做研究。我一直在听一些播客，我最喜欢的一些播客……等等，你一直在听播客？在几乎四年之后，你开始听播客了，现在你做完了？我一直都在听
podcasts it's just i predominantly listen to economics podcasts. I listen to Planet Money and The Indicator, which is Planet Money's daily podcast, and sometimes for economics. But I primarily listen to Planet Money. Sometimes I listen to audiobooks now, too. Hello, Ramona. She's in the background. Hi. Bryce is ignoring you.
播客，只是我主要听经济类播客。我听《Planet Money》和《The Indicator》（这是《Planet Money》的每日播客），有时也听经济类节目。但我主要听《Planet Money》。有时我现在也听有声读物。你好，Ramona。她在背景里。嗨。Bryce 在无视你。
Hi. Oh, the whole family's here. I'm sorry to hear that you're feeling below the weather. He's saying that he's sorry to hear that you're feeling sick. Thank you. Hopefully you bounce back. Did you tell him what you made me do this morning? I did. Yes, I did tell him about the pigeon rescue.
嗨。哦，全家人都在这儿。听到你身体不舒服我很难过。他说他很遗憾听到你生病了。谢谢。希望你能早日康复。你告诉他你今天早上让我做什么了吗？我说了。是的，我告诉他关于救鸽子的事了。
But don't you feel good that we saved a life? That pigeon would not have made it. him about the pigeon rescue but don't you feel good that you that we saved a life that pigeon would not have made it yeah and i also feel great that you put me in a highly pathogenic okay i i neglected to mention this part when we got to the bird rescue place there was a big sign on the store on the door saying do not come inside risk of bird influenza. So there is that. I was already compromising. There is that. I did. Oh, yeah.
但你不觉得我们救了一条生命感觉很好吗？那只鸽子本来活不下来的。告诉他关于救鸽子的事，但你不觉得我们救了一条生命感觉很好吗？那只鸽子本来活不下来的。是的，而且我也觉得很棒，你让我处于高致病性……好吧，我忘了提这一部分，当我们到达鸟类救援中心时，门上有一个大牌子，写着“禁止入内，有禽流感风险”。所以就是这样。我已经妥协了。就是这样。我做了。哦，是的。
So anyways, I've been listening to some of my favorite podcasts like Planet Money and The Indicator. And sometimes on Planet Money, they do a listener quiz. And I actually remember that on another podcast I've listened to a lot, which is the British History Podcast, which that got me through COVID. It's a podcast by an American guy about British history. And there's also a American history podcast by a British guy. But I listened to like 500 episodes, just like whenever I would go biking, I'd listen to an episode. And every few episodes, they would have a listener quiz.
总之，我一直在听我最喜欢的一些播客，比如《Planet Money》和《The Indicator》。有时在《Planet Money》上，他们会进行听众测验。我确实记得在另一个我听过很多的播客上，也就是《英国历史播客》，它陪我度过了新冠疫情。这是一个美国人制作的关于英国历史的播客。还有一个英国人制作的美国历史播客。但我听了大约 500 集，就像我每次骑自行车时都会听一集。每隔几集，他们就会进行一次听众测验。
I can't say I always did great on the listener quizzes because British history, there are a lot of names. But I think we ought to do some listener quizzes. And I think we ought to, well, we should do what Planet Money does, which is we should bring somebody on to do the Planet Quiz live, just like some other great NPR radio shows like Wait, Wait, Don't Tell Me. So yeah, I think we should let people enter in, and then one lucky listener can come on the podcast, tell us a bit about what they're doing,
我不能说我在听众测验中总是表现得很好，因为英国历史有很多名字。但我认为我们应该做一些听众测验。我认为我们应该……好吧，我们应该像《Planet Money》那样做，我们应该请人来现场参加“星球测验”，就像其他一些很棒的 NPR 广播节目一样，比如《Wait, Wait, Don't Tell Me》。所以是的，我认为我们应该让人们报名，然后一位幸运的听众可以来到播客，告诉我们一点他们在做什么，
and play to win some sort of prize. Yeah, I guess. I guess maybe if it's a thing on other podcasts. I mean, they're going to sound... Shouldn't you know?
并玩游戏赢取某种奖品。是的，我想吧。我想也许如果这是其他播客上的一个环节的话。我是说，他们听起来会……你不应该知道吗？
Don't you listen to a lot of podcasts? I listen. I'm like probably... I listen to more podcasts than anyone I know, but they... None of them are like history. In fact, I don't think
你不听很多播客吗？我听。我可能……我听的播客比我认识的任何人都多，但它们……没有一个是关于历史的。事实上，我不认为
there's this... I've ever heard a quiz i think we could do a quiz i think we could do this we can make this happen yeah i mean uh how about we listen folks if you would like to have see the thing is is if we ask the listener i was just about to say if we ask the listener to go and leave a comment uh if they would or would not like or maybe i'll actually i'll put a poll out but the thing is is it's going to be heavily skewed because if i was a listener i would vote yes to that regardless if i wanted a quiz just for an opportunity to go on like my favorite podcast like i would just be like oh they're going to bring on
我听说过测验。我想我们可以做一个测验，我想我们可以做到这一点，我们可以让它发生。是的，我是说，嗯，听众朋友们，如果你想……问题是，如果我们问听众……我刚才正想说，如果我们问听众去留个言，他们是否愿意，或者也许我会发起一个投票。但问题是，这会严重偏颇，因为如果我是听众，无论我是否想要测验，我都会投赞成票，仅仅是为了有机会参加我最喜欢的播客，就像我会觉得，哦，他们要请
people that sounds fun so is it really that people want to hear a quiz or do people want to have like, you know, their voice highlighted? Like I would love to go on like a bunch of podcasts that I really like. Well, okay. Maybe we just, maybe we'll just pick a random listener to come on the podcast, but I think the quiz part would make it fun. Come on. You, you always, you always, you always say I don't contribute. Here I am. I come up with the whole thing. I'll even make the quiz. Well, okay. Maybe that's a step too far because then I'd have to actually go and listen to past episodes. Oh, wait.
人来，那听起来很有趣。所以人们是真的想听测验，还是想让自己的声音被突出显示？就像我很想参加我真正喜欢的很多播客一样。好吧，好吧。也许我们只是随机挑选一位听众来参加播客，但我认为测验部分会很有趣。来吧。你总是说我不贡献。我来了。我想出了整个方案。我甚至会制作测验。好吧，好吧。也许那有点过分了，因为那样我就得真的去听过去的剧集了。哦，等等。
The quiz is based on our podcast? Yeah. The quizzes are based upon – like that's what I've typically seen, the format, where you ask some questions upon topics that were in recent episodes. Oh, that sounds way less interesting. My thought would, is it was going to be like either like a programming language quiz podcast or like a C plus plus 23 quiz podcast.
测验是基于我们的播客吗？是的。测验是基于——我通常看到的就是这种形式，你针对最近剧集中的主题提出一些问题。哦，那听起来没那么有趣。我的想法是，它要么是一个编程语言测验播客，要么是一个 C++ 23 测验播客。
We can do the quiz in whatever way, shape or form you'd like. I just want to have a quiz. I mean, we've had quizzes before and i think the the listener's favorite quiz has got to be that i'm not taking no but that's the best is because watching and listening to you squirm is everybody's not favorite pastime but just uh you know we uh anyway so maybe coming to a theater or podcast player, player near you, user quizzes.
我们可以以你喜欢的任何方式、形式进行测验。我只是想进行一次测验。我是说，我们以前做过测验，我认为听众最喜欢的测验一定是……我不接受“不”。但那是最好的，因为看着你局促不安是每个人最喜欢的消遣，不，只是……你知道，我们……总之，也许在附近的剧院或播客播放器上，用户测验即将到来。
Not today, though, because we don't have a guest and we don't have a quiz. There were three topics you wanted to talk about. One of them is boring. I got a fourth one. And the other two were rotate and MCSS, or otherwise known as maximum contiguous Subarray Sum, otherwise known as Cadain's Algorithm. What would you like? I don't remember why I wanted to talk about that one. So let's, okay, what was the one that was boring?
不过今天不行，因为我们没有嘉宾，也没有测验。你有三个想谈的话题。其中一个是无聊的。我还有一个第四个。另外两个是 rotate 和 MCSS，也就是最大连续子数组和，也称为 Kadane 算法。你想要什么？我不记得我为什么想谈那个了。所以，好吧，那个无聊的话题是什么？
No, I'm not going to bring that one up because I don't want to. Oh, the elevator one? Yeah. So I'm... Anyways, how long have we been talking for because we haven't really said anything interesting should we uh you know no i know what do you mean we haven't said anything interesting i think i think i think the listeners i think we should have my elevator guy on to explain to us the the algorithms and logics behind elevators all right yeah if he wants to come on sure uh but no let him know let him let him know in advance that i'll be hostile and uh i i will i i will let him know that okay so let's talk about let's talk about rotate all right
不，我不会提那个，因为我不想。哦，电梯那个？是的。所以我是……总之，我们聊了多久了，因为我们还没说任何有趣的事情。我们应该……你知道，不，我知道。你是什么意思，我们没说任何有趣的事情？我想听众……我想我们应该请我的电梯专家来向我们解释电梯背后的算法和逻辑。好吧，是的，如果他愿意来，当然可以。但别让他知道，提前告诉他我会表现得很有敌意，我会让他知道的。好吧，那我们来谈谈 rotate 吧。
seeing as that was the most riveting podcast you've listened to on ADSP the podcast and at the moment depending on how long this little segment at the end goes it's probably going to be the shortest episode yet I checked the shortest episode to date was 16 minutes the average is 33 so we're way under what it needs to be but I just couldn't let you suffer through the elevator and pigeon conversations that I was so eager to have with Bryce. We are adding a couple of technical tidbits, a couple conference announcements, and reviews of talks that I have watched recently. So first things first, I'm going to be at two conferences in October. The first is Lambda World, which is being held in Cadiz, Spain from October 2nd to 4th.
鉴于那是你在 ADSP 播客上听过的最引人入胜的播客，而且目前，取决于最后这一小段持续多久，这可能是迄今为止最短的一集。我查了一下，最短的一集是 16 分钟，平均是 33 分钟，所以我们远低于所需时长，但我实在不能让你忍受我急于和 Bryce 进行的电梯和鸽子对话。我们正在添加一些技术小知识、一些会议公告以及我最近观看的演讲的评论。首先，我将在十月份参加两个会议。第一个是 Lambda World，将于 10 月 2 日至 4 日在西班牙加的斯举行。
I will be giving a talk entitled The Power of Function Composition. And the workshop is entitled TASA Programming in BQN, WeWa, CAP, and APL. So if you're interested in array languages or functional languages and you are in the area or not in the area and interested in traveling, be sure to check that conference out. The second conference is a brand new C++ conference. You might have heard of it already. C++ Under the Sea, a play on Phil Nash's C++ plus plus on c it's being held in breda netherlands
我将发表题为《函数组合的力量》的演讲。研讨会的题目是《BQN、WeWa、CAP 和 APL 中的 TASA 编程》。所以如果你对数组语言或函数式语言感兴趣，并且你在该地区，或者不在该地区但有兴趣旅行，请务必查看那个会议。第二个会议是一个全新的 C++ 会议。你可能已经听说过了。C++ Under the Sea，这是对 Phil Nash 的 C++ on C 的戏仿，它将在荷兰布雷达举行。
hopefully i'm pronouncing that correctly it's just outside of rotterdam i believe it's on october 11th is the day of the conference october 10th is a workshop day both bryce and i will be there i'll be giving a talk on arrays fusion and cpu versus the gpu and bryce will be there. I'll be giving a talk on arrays, fusion, and CPU versus the GPU. And Bryce will be giving, I believe, one of his Think Parallel talks. I'm not sure if it is the one that he gave at ACCU and CPP North or if it's the second edition. I'm hoping it's the second edition, but maybe we'll talk about that on a future episode. Speaking of the Think Parallel talk, so I'm gonna recap very briefly
希望我发音正确，它就在鹿特丹郊外，我相信会议日期是 10 月 11 日，10 月 10 日是研讨会日。我和 Bryce 都会参加。我将发表关于数组、融合以及 CPU 与 GPU 的演讲，Bryce 也会在那里。我将发表关于数组、融合以及 CPU 与 GPU 的演讲。Bryce 将发表我相信是他“Think Parallel”系列演讲中的一个。我不确定是他之前在 ACCU 和 CPP North 上发表的那个，还是第二版。我希望是第二版，但也许我们会在以后的剧集中讨论。说到“Think Parallel”演讲，我将非常简要地回顾一下
the three talks that I have watched in the first five days of September. And one of those talks was Think Parallel. I can recommend this talk. It's definitely not Bryce's best talk, but it is a good talk. However, it is very dense and I'm not sure he achieved the goal
我在九月的前五天观看的三场演讲。其中一场就是“Think Parallel”。我可以推荐这场演讲。它绝对不是 Bryce 最好的演讲，但它是一场好演讲。然而，它非常密集，我不确定他是否达到了他想要实现的目标。
he was aiming to achieve. I've read a couple of the comments in the YouTube comment section that basically said they enjoyed the talk, but they're going to need to rewatch it a couple times, especially towards the end. It is quite complicated and there is a ton of code
我读了 YouTube 评论区的一些评论，基本上说他们喜欢这场演讲，但他们需要重看几次，特别是在最后部分。它非常复杂，而且有大量的代码，
that potentially it could have been split into like a part one and part two. But if you're interested in how scan, inclusive scan is and can be implemented in parallel, be sure to check that talk out. The other talk or one of the other talks that I watched was by John Bandella. I believe there was a co-speaker that did not speak. I can't remember their name off the top of my head. And they are two Google engineers.
可能可以拆分成第一部分和第二部分。但如果你对 scan、inclusive scan 如何以及可以在并行中实现感兴趣，请务必查看那场演讲。我观看的另一场演讲或其中一场演讲是由 John Bandella 发表的。我相信有一位没有发言的共同演讲者。我一时想不起他们的名字。他们是两位谷歌工程师。
John was the one presenting at C++ Now. And I should add, Bryce's talk was from ACCU 2024. And John's talk was on Repel, which is a sibling library to Abseil. And it is a alternative to the ranges library that is in the C++ standard library, as well as Flux, which is a competitor to that, and RangeV3, which was the initial implementation of C++20's ranges library. The difference is, is that it is an eager library, not a lazy library, and the API is incredibly different. They don't overload the pipe operator. And therefore, you need to pass things in a kind of Lisp style. And in order to compose things, you have to make use of a RPL colon colon compose. And in order to apply things, you have to make use of a RPL colon colon apply. Honestly, the aesthetics of the library
John 是在 C++ Now 上演讲的那位。我应该补充一点，Bryce 的演讲来自 ACCU 2024。John 的演讲是关于 Repel 的，它是 Abseil 的姊妹库。它是 C++ 标准库中 ranges 库的替代品，以及 Flux（它的竞争对手）和 RangeV3（C++20 ranges 库的最初实现）。区别在于，它是一个 eager（急切）库，而不是 lazy（惰性）库，而且 API 非常不同。他们没有重载管道运算符。因此，你需要以一种 Lisp 风格传递东西。为了组合事物，你必须使用 RPL::compose。为了应用事物，你必须使用 RPL::apply。老实说，这个库的美学
was not a huge fan of. However, it could be much more performant because it's obviously a completely different design than the ranges. And it also claims to be a lot safer because it doesn't suffer from a lot of the dangling pointer issues that ranges has famously been criticized for.
我不是特别喜欢。然而，它的性能可能会更高，因为它显然与 ranges 的设计完全不同。它还声称更安全，因为它不会受到 ranges 经常被批评的许多悬空指针问题的影响。
And unfortunately, it's not open source. So I would have definitely taken this library for a spin and benchmarked it against the Flux range V3 and C++ standard ranges, as I've done in the past. But it's not open source. So until it is, we won't know which is better. But they said that they were working towards open sourcing it in the future,
不幸的是，它不是开源的。所以我肯定会试用这个库，并将其与 Flux、RangeV3 和 C++ 标准 ranges 进行基准测试，就像我过去做的那样。但它不是开源的。所以直到它开源之前，我们不知道哪个更好。但他们说他们正在努力在未来将其开源，
if folks are interested. I'm interested. So if John, you hear this, hopefully Google can work towards that. And the third and final talk, which was the best talk of the three by far was Dave Abraham's keynote that just came out a couple days ago from C++ on C. It was about at a high level, the Hilo language, but actually not so much. I don't think he even showed any Hilo code. He might have showed a tiny bit, but it was more of a philosophical talk about MVS, mutable value semantics, and the history of where MVS and Hilo came from in Swift. And he mentions Stepanov and generic programming.
如果大家感兴趣的话。我很感兴趣。所以如果 John 你听到了，希望谷歌能朝着这个方向努力。第三场也是最后一场演讲，也是这三场中最好的一场，是 Dave Abraham 在几天前 C++ on C 大会上发表的主题演讲。它在高层面上是关于 Hilo 语言的，但实际上并没有那么多。我不认为他展示了任何 Hilo 代码。他可能展示了一点点，但它更多的是关于 MVS（可变值语义）的哲学演讲，以及 MVS 和 Hilo 在 Swift 中起源的历史。他提到了 Stepanov 和泛型编程。
Absolutely fantastic. Also, he shouts out Ken Iverson and APL in the first couple minutes of the talk. We absolutely love that, folks. We absolutely love that. And Dave is just a fantastic speaker across the board. We cannot recommend this talk highly enough. Definitely the best of the three. In the pipeline, oh, also I should mention, RPL is the namespace on the Repel library. Apparently, Repel is a synonym for abseil. But originally,
绝对精彩。此外，他在演讲的前几分钟向 Ken Iverson 和 APL 致敬。我们绝对喜欢这一点，伙计们。我们绝对喜欢这一点。Dave 是一位非常出色的演讲者。我们强烈推荐这场演讲。绝对是这三场中最好的一场。在筹备中，哦，我还应该提到，RPL 是 Repel 库的命名空间。显然，Repel 是 abseil 的同义词。但最初，
RPL stood for ranges pipeline library. So fun fact, if you watch the talk, you will also have known that in the pipeline, two of the talks that I have not started watching, but plan to watch in the next week or two, implementing ranges and views in C++ by Roy Barkin from C++ Now 2024, and reintroduction to generic programming for C++ Engineers by Nick DeMarco, who is one of the team members on the STL lab at Adobe with Dave Abrahams, David Sankel, and of course, Sean Parent.
RPL 代表 ranges pipeline library。所以有趣的事实是，如果你看了这场演讲，你也会知道在筹备中，我有两场演讲还没开始看，但计划在接下来的一两周内看：Roy Barkin 在 C++ Now 2024 上发表的《在 C++ 中实现 ranges 和 views》，以及 Nick DeMarco 发表的《C++ 工程师泛型编程再介绍》，他是 Adobe STL 实验室的团队成员之一，与 Dave Abrahams、David Sankel 和 Sean Parent 一起。
So links to all those talks will be in the show notes. Stay tuned to next episode where we actually talk about something technical and interesting, std rotate. Be sure to check the show notes. Stay tuned to next episode where we actually talk about something technical and interesting std rotate. Be sure to check these show notes
所以所有这些演讲的链接都会在节目说明中。请继续关注下一集，届时我们将讨论一些技术性和有趣的内容：std rotate。请务必查看节目说明。请继续关注下一集，届时我们将讨论一些技术性和有趣的内容：std rotate。请务必查看这些节目说明，
either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast dot com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts comments and questions.
无论是在你的播客应用程序中，还是在 ADSP the podcast dot com 上，都可以找到我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality high quantity that is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline.
感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量、高数量，这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。
Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的标语是“充满信息点缀的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。